so our evaluation puts the Donald at 2.9
billion and okay that's taken into
account all of the assets and
liabilities and cash flows that we could
find so if the liquidator today that
would be what he would walk away with in
suitcases yeah yeah well yeah absolutely
very very nice suitcases but this is
traditionally difficult it's not just
the Donald and his own inflated sense of
self-worth but it's hard to estimate the
net worth of somebody who works in real
estate
I absolutely we the benefit we have here
for his most valuable properties is that
New York City is one of the most closely
watched real estate markets we have a
lot of really good data there but he
also has the golf courses and resort
properties and those are harder to
penetrate now he doesn't own a lot of
those though right through licensed or
his name is the brand they've taken on
so there are many buildings throughout
the world and a few in the u.s. that
have Donald's brand on them that he
neither built developed nor owns he
collects licensing revenue from from
those buildings they put his name on
there with the hopes of selling condos
and hotel rooms at higher prices how do
you calculate the value of his brand so
we are currently only calculating the
value of his brand based on the cash
flow disclosed for royalties and
licensing as fvc this is very wide value
for each right it was like you know
between 50 and $250,000 there's a
notoriety here in that but I'm thinking
then again mr. Trump and his staff did
not comment on your work right correct
okay they did not comment fair did
anybody do this with George Bush the
younger or for that matter George Bush
the older we said now they got a lot of
oil wells and we really don't know what
they're worth why is this a big deal
this is a big deal because Trump has
historically and continues to make it a
big deal he he talked about valuation
the real issue here is he said ten
billion that he said ten million and
whether it's our estimate or someone
else's estimate there's slight
variations between those but none of
them get look let's walk through this
there's an equity valuation and
everybody look at the article out on
Bloomberg politics it's really meant and
then you overlay two point whatever plus
three point three Trump will write not
good will not bad will Donnell
well whatever and then you then
typically real-estate animals like mr.
Trump I can see three of his buildings
in our set design here on the set I mean
I mean within that they roll the debt on
top of that that's that's a normal real
estate dialogue obviously you say they
shouldn't do that well you so the nice
thing about the FEC disclosure that we
don't have for all billionaires is a
sense of liabilities in what buildings
they belong in so we're able to
calculate as a separate asset all of the
liabilities they have on these buildings
so Nike town so many of our viewers of
listeners on Nike town on 57th what I'm
so active in the gym I'm their weekly
yes Nike town he owns that right so he
owns the leasehold to Nike town boots on
me so he doesn't have the deed but he
owns the rights to lease it out to in
this case Nike so when you look at the
bat value of a building versus the value
of a leasehold our experts that we
talked to told us the tree was about
attend official things like tripled to
go to go into the weeds here is this
triple net lease where they're free and
clear and you've got a pure income
stream from mr. Trump so he's no he's
still paying rent back to the owner of
the company and for a while that was
incredibly low that there was less than
a million dollars that recently kicked
up to 6% of the property's fair market
value which leaves him a lot of room for
negotiation it's okay because Tony
Dwyers buying a pair of shoes a month
for the office I would argue that it's
significant that we figure out how much
he's worth because if he's gonna finance
his own run for president there's a
difference between somebody who's worth
worth 10 billion dollars how they find
out to run and somebody who's worth
three billion dollars three billion
dollars mean what it used to be that
kind of thing didn't work for Malcolm
Forbes yeah
Steve for swarms so that I mean that's
one of those things where we got to be
careful of looking what what he's worth
and what it really means to the whole
thing he's not gonna find anything
that's a golf course worse in Scotland
so the golf courses are valued anywhere
from about 50 million to 150 million in
in our value all right Kayla Melba I got
to jump in here we'll send you to
Scotland to figure that one out
Reid is in Richard Reubens article on
bloomberg.com